great to see you again we're here for
round three so excited that they might
be round four is it for waiting one two
three is it
I'm honored four Wow
so I told you this beforehand but I woke
up this morning and thought you know
Colin's been on a bunch of times we
never run out of things to say you're
such a great guest it's gonna be awesome
no matter what but you're always so
quick to talk about Jenna and what an
integral amazing part
she you know she plays in this whole
thing as your partner you know in every
aspect of what you do and I thought well
let's let's hear from her directly so I
set it up with an extra mic and had it
all ready to go cuz I'm pretty sure
every other time I've seen you you you
guys have been together so I had no
reason to think that she wouldn't be
coming as I knew she came to LA yes we
are pretty much always together but she
hopped on a plane last night to go get
our dog and bring them back to Jackson
Hole so so now I feel bad that I didn't
think of this a couple days ago yes
I'm bummed because I think hearing from
Jenna is the most important well Jenna I
always have a chair for for you here and
we'll see how this goes today if it goes
well then or maybe I'll just bring Jenna
back without you yeah I think that that
will be done with you dude we've talked
about a good conversation and you know
if this goes well we'll just delete it
and we'll just come back I did hit play
today though as far as I can tell right
now it's recording so that's good
Congrats man so many so many things to
congratulate you on the book the 12 year
anniversary of surviving the burns which
you just passed that date comes ago
right same as the book came out this
past week and also the Drake crossing
which we're going to talk about as well
yes that's a lot it's been a it's been a
busy period of time but yeah it was a
coincidental that as you know books book
published on Tuesdays that's right I
don't know why that's the rule but
that's the way it were I didn't know
that it's my first book but it turns out
all books are published on Tuesday
and January 14th happened to be a
Tuesday this year which coincided with
the of 12 year anniversary of my sex was
that coincidental or when you looked at
dates did you work that out with it was
actually shortly coincidental we
actually originally the pub date was
February 4th which is the day after the
Democratic primary and Iowa caucuses I
thought that might not be the best day
so we moved it to January 28th but then
when I was in the middle of the row kind
of momentum was building towards the
finish line of that and the publisher
decided to move it up to the 14th and
Jenna said okay we could do that just so
you know it's a really you know special
day in Colin's life so it was actually
completely coincidental but as one of my
more tragic moments of my life probably
the most tragic on December or January
14th it's nice to have a beautiful
rebirth of creativity and art to put
into the world on that day so nice to
have that memory going right so a year
ago around this time I bumped into you
in a hotel lobby you just got back from
your solo expedition across Antarctica
and you were doing a little press around
it you hadn't even gone home yet and now
one year later you've got another crazy
adventure under your belt and a book to
celebrate it and I look at the Drake
crossing and I'm like that's the
greatest book marketing trick of all
time right not only do I have a book
coming out actually it's something
amazing that I can tell all these media
people so there you are back on the
Today Show back on you know Jimmy Fallon
doing the rounds the whole thing you
just came from New York yes it's been
certainly humbling the interest and
excitement and all of this and just
really grateful to be able to have this
book out in the world and I'm sure we'll
get into it but you know the book is
called the impossible first but really
my biggest return on investment for this
book and I've been saying this but I
really mean it which is I'm grateful
people that want to hear my story about
my life and as you mentioned it's really
not just about mine it's about jenna's
it's about overcoming obstacles its
hardships it's how we built this it's
our heart it's our creativity it's all
this but the biggest thing I want is
when people sat down this book the
impossible first it's not to call me up
and be like wow Colin that was so
amazing across an article I want people
to set this book down and go wow you did
something that people said was
impossible now I can go do that and take
that into
my own life so that's that's all man
that's the beauty the poetry and the
other thing how was the writing process
for you man you know I people think you
know you've set these World Records you
walked across an article solo never rode
a boat across Drake Passage but I would
say writing a book may have been the
hardest thing I've ever done or
certainly up there it really challenged
me to you know flex a different muscle
in the mind the creative process and
also I've been I've been journaling
since I was a kid so I've been
journaling you know back into my early
teenage years maybe even before that so
I've Holly's journals and video
recordings audio recordings in my life
and so it was cool and cathartic to go
back through that but it also kind of
brings up different things when you're
writing you know like I said it's not
just a memoir of this you know 54 days
of crossing Antarctica but as I'm in
Antarctica and I'm having all these
vivid memories in my mind I kind of
flashback to all these you know
important moments through my life and so
to sift through that and to you know
decide on which ones to share and how to
bring those to life and you know maybe
have deeper conversations with my family
and other people that experience those
moments that you know my parents divorce
um different things in my life
ultimately I'm really proud of how it
came out but it was a challenging
process and a beautiful one yeah I mean
that's that's what you get from most
people yeah write a book I mean David
Goggin said the same thing I mean it
certainly was my experience writing a
book yeah it's yeah and we had we we
share another thing in common which is
that we had the same editor yes we did
oh what a guy what a guy and I say rich
I'm grateful grich's names on the back
of my book and wears him wait the book
it hey we got you guys go grab it's in
it's in the container I thought I had it
setting here well one of you guys go
grab it so we have a sitting out here
yeah that's the most important thing my
blurb on the back cover most important
thing is that rich rolls name on my book
but no shout out to Rick Corrigan we
both worked with the same editor that
you worked with many years ago to
complete coincidence that's the case
yeah what a guy he did a great job on my
book he certainly made it a lot better
and he devoted a lot of time to it yeah
I think he's a really great super
talented to roll up the sleeves and kind
of get in there and kind of live that
side by side was I'm grateful to have
him and amazing that we both had him
work on both of our books yeah and how's
it doing I mean it came out Tuesday
it's killing it on Amazon I check the
numbers yeah sure you have very here's
the thing about you straight up dude
super friendly
you know jovial guy conversational
charismatic but you're a stone-cold
killer oh you are man there is no way
that you do what you do without having
like the eyes on the prize man I
appreciate I'm gonna take that as a
combat was what I wanted Jenna here to
talk eyes like come on tell me what it's
like when you know back at home when no
one's looking and you're plotting it's
like this this dude is competitive well
I mean yes I guess I'll miss you too
take that as a compliment there is a
I'll taught the book writing process is
interesting and that you know as times
and as you know kind of I do think that
I orient towards the positive and
towards the positivity and that and as
we dive into the roll up the sleeves in
the book I'm working with my publisher
Rick and the whole Scribner team over
there you know is helping me with the
editing process and you know choosing
the photos that we choose and all this
kind of stuff and there was kind of in
the work session there there would be
some tensions arise not negative but
just implicit you know collaboration
type of tensions and a couple of times I
turned them and I was like you hired you
you bought this idea of a book of a guy
who walked across an article by himself
you did realize that there was a intense
really hyper focused element I mean ever
like they're like yeah I guess that
makes sense right so yeah of course
there is the duality of that but I think
that is you had to flex a little bit
here and there not flex but I just I
just care I know that some people I mean
I don't I can't save anyone specific but
I imagine there have been books written
where people haven't cared as much maybe
or have said like oh I want to write
this I wanted to be good or whatever but
I'm doing ten of other things I'm not
like hyper focus on it for me if I was
ever gonna sit down and write a book I
really wanted you know I cared about
every word every sentence every story of
your life exactly in the chronicle of
your life I think also a lot of authors
particularly first-time authors don't
realize that they have any power in the
in the conversation like well these are
the publishers they know they say you
should do this so I guess that's what
you're supposed to do and they end up
with a weird cover
ya know something that doesn't work or
because they didn't feel like they they
could actually assert themselves and be
part of that conversation of course the
publisher is gonna have final approval
over all of this stuff but you know I
found that if you pick your battles and
and you're strong about the things that
are most important that you know you can
have a say you should have and I think
that the thing to me ultimately that I'm
most proud of about this book is there
it is right there there it is rituals
name on the back cover of the hardcover
forget about this part yeah it's just
right there on the back no but the thing
that I think was the most important to
me in this creative process that might
have been initially at odds with the
publisher but I think ultimately
everyone is very pleased including you
know Rick and the whole team are really
pleased with the outcome was on the
surface it was like wow you cross an
article solo there is a genre of books
that are about edge of your these'd
adventure memoirs and I by the way I
love that genre
I'm very well-read in that genre I've
read voraciously and like I've read them
all I love I love that Krakauer kind of
hundred percent or you know in you know
endurance them you know about the
Shackleton book I mean there's so many
in that category
again I love you know touching the void
or these books that Chronicle like an
epic intense like thing and my book the
impossible first of course is about that
it uses Antarctica as this you know sort
of through line of the entire chronology
of the book but to me that is not the
book that I wanted to write the book
that I wanted to write in the last
chapter of the book is titled infinite
love which might not be what someone
might expect out of a book about you
know a male guy doing this hard thing
alone in Antarctica and so there is
these gritty elements and the
vulnerability of the intense things that
I went to but it's woven through with
you know relationships there's a lot of
people who have read this book who you
know female audience you know we know a
single mother from or ever saying like
hey I don't really read the genre but
this touched me because of these
universal elements of love or compassion
or there's a whole piece on
entrepreneurship and how we actually
built behind the behind the scenes built
this and so to me that was a little bit
at odds initially with someone saying
like we wanted to write a book about a
hardcore adventure and I don't think the
hardcore adventurer audience will be
disappointed
by this book but I think there is just a
much broader reach to it which was super
important to me because that's the the
elements the human elements that I
deeply care about sharing right I mean
one of the conversations that I had at
length with Rick when I was working on
my book something he pointed out to me
that I still think about all the time is
the difference between inspirational and
aspirational and he you know he's like
listen you know LeBron James
you know Michael Jordan they're like
inspirational like you can read about
them you can be inspired by their
example
but that reader can't aspire to be that
person right and he's like you're he
talking to me he was like you're
aspirational like you've done some
really hard things but you people can
see some version of their own story in
your story and so the narrative really
that was kind of like the architecture
around wit you know that kind of
informed how I tell this story and I see
like what you've done is much crazier
and more difficult and all these world
records and all of that but there is you
know with kind of overcoming the
obstacles and the burn burn you know
like all the things that you've gone
through in your life there is a there is
a threat of that I think that that makes
you relatable to an average person so
they they're not going to go across
Antarctica but I think in reading this
and you did a phenomenal job
you can see you know aspects of your own
self and your shortcomings and your
victories in the way that you tell the
story and I think that that's the
launchpad from which people can find
their own you know inspiration to 100%
and like I say you know it's a you
started off with mentioning Jenna you
know I always say it's a shame that my
name is the the name on the front cover
of this book cause it's not just my
story it's my story it's Jenna story
it's a story of my family it's you know
the ups and downs of you know divorce
and our family but ultimately this
amicable crazy Ohana loving family but
you know from the outside potentially
broken look you know into that and
there's a lot of different elements that
are just were important for me to share
which is just kind of my truth in my
journey and hopefully that connects with
people in a way even if it's not direct
to like I said the walk if you want to
walk Christ article by yourself I highly
recommend it I have gotten a lot of tips
and advice I'd love to love to see this
is not on how-to there's a lot of how
I'm crossing in America and you know you
talk about like the creative process a
little bit we've been talking about and
one of the concepts that we talked about
in there is this idea of you know Jenna
and I sitting down with the whiteboard
you know mapping out our idea and we
would talk about in the book as from
whiteboard into reality and one of the
questions I've got from so many people
including you know people who have
reached out from hearing me on this
podcast it says like I have a big idea I
want to do this incredible thing I want
to run across America or I want to you
know could be anything I wanted to take
a trip around the world with my best
friend or something like that and I get
I do get this how-to question which is
like so how did you do it were you just
born with the trust-fund you have like a
ton of money and you can just do
whatever you want you know I'm like you
know the quote unquote real job and in
this book and I do my best to answer
those people's questions I love when
people write reach out and I respond as
many people as I possibly can
but in this book we dive in this process
of Jenna and I literally you know bring
you to this room and so you know
one-bedroom apartment we've got a
whiteboard on the wall we're writing our
ideas don't want to set a world record
want to start a non-profit and inspire
kids like you know want to reach people
in this way this and then the bare bones
facts come down it's like but you need a
few hundred thousand dollars to do that
how do you even start a non-profit all
this red tape or whatever and the book
also brings you through pieces of that
journey of us you know taking our idea
from the whiteboard and the struggles
and the challenges and the thousand
doors that slam in our face of people
saying you're not going to do this in
our interior dog a lot dialogue of us
doubting ourselves and ultimately being
able to come together with her and I and
this sort of just perseverance through a
not just the Antarctica crossing itself
but the perseverance of actually taking
an idea into action and that's the piece
but I do think as many as others but
certainly one of the pieces that I think
connects widely in that I don't care who
you are you're listening this I know you
have a big idea inside of you I know you
have your own impossible for something
you want to achieve something that's out
there but maybe in the back of your mind
you're thinking oh I don't know maybe
I'm not the right person for it if I
listened to the first 999 people that
told me that too we wouldn't be sitting
here having this conversation and the
book kind of brings through that process
and like I said hopefully someone sets
the book down and goes you know what I'm
gonna actually go after that impossible
first now cuz I believe I can do it but
doing it through storytelling not
through here's the 10 steps no it's like
it's like this is how we
let me walk you through like the
nonlinear inelegant you know two steps
forward five steps backwards you know
the book is not a book it is a memoir
written in prose and storytelling the
entire time but can read between the
lines of just our story and hopefully
people take inspiration from it like I
said it was humbling process to be act
asked to write a book and I'm grateful
to be able to share it with the world
and hopefully it has well received and
now it's in the world it's in the world
just like that I was watching The Today
Show and a clip that you shared after
doing your interview you're outside and
you're signing books and you're kind of
like shaking hands with the people you
know the people that kind of congregate
outside the show and I was like wow
that's so crazy I was just thinking it
was only a year ago when I ran into you
in New York and you were taking meetings
on the book like it wasn't that long ago
and like look what you've done in a year
it was real make that happen it was it's
crazy I know you're interviewing me but
I actually would like to interview you
for a sec when we were so you said so
rich and I we've been friends for
several years now but we coincidentally
you were in New York City I was in New
York City when I got back from my
Nordica right you had texted me and said
hey congratulations this seer in New
York you probably slam but where are you
we text each other we realize we're
actually in the same boat we run into
each other and elevator coming down but
then the what was amazing is a group of
my friends had asked to kind of come
together and kind of hear the story
after the press the media it was not
like a press event it's just like my
friends in the townhouse apartment kind
of a fireside chat totally QA before I
had done a bunch of interviews I've been
asked about the story a million times
and you came that night and that was
first of all just really special to me
that you came and you know sat there
with my you know group of close friends
and I was just it's one thing to talk to
a roomful of strangers that do a lot in
my public speaking but there's something
about the intimacy of the actual people
in your close community who you have
deep connections with asking questions
there's a first to me there's an added
level of vulnerability to that and a
question I guess have for you since I'm
interviewing you now for ten minutes
yeah I'm only pretty so far yeah which
is I'm just curious for me the anchor
point the anchor point for me writing
this book actually was writing that I
did myself and sure knowing that I did
in the immediate aftermath so before I
even left Antarctica and I'll Culp's it
in through that first week or so in New
York not to say that my brain or
anything was like polluted from the
authenticity of the experience but as
you know with many things you've done in
your life like you get a little bit
further away from me and so I kept
coming back to come of those anchors and
particularly some of the writing that I
did just myself and my journal alone on
the ice before I even got picked up and
flown away but I reflect on that moment
that room that you happen to actually be
sitting in as one of the I guess really
pure moments of that entire experience
for me to be able to sit there and share
in the way I did and not that I don't
think it's pure now but there was just
something about I guess that it was just
I was still hadn't slept in my own
bright I mean it was a wild moment I
have a vivid memory of that that evening
and you know a couple things first of
all yeah you it was literally right
after you completed this so been alone
New York City exactly to New York City
you hadn't even gone home yet you still
had all your gear and and yeah so I show
up at this townhouse and I think these
were people that you had gone to Israel
with yes I'm from the reality community
and Israel and other things yeah and so
this small group of people gathered
around you and you began to share your
story and my recollection of that was
that I was so impressed with how how
much command you had over the story
already like it it just happened but you
rifled out you were telling these
stories and you were kind of relating
the experience but you've had such a
command over what was important about it
to convey with everybody else and I've
seen you give your keynote that you go
around and do frequently now in the wake
of that and it's not that different than
what you delivered on that night it's
pretty much the same thing yeah so I
remember thinking like wow he already
has a grip I'm like how to tell this not
only used to do it like he already knows
how to tell the story like sometimes it
takes a while for you to figure out like
okay what is it about this that people
are interested in and you got to have to
play around with it in front of a live
audience to figure out what those
important things are and the more you
tell it the more you the more it starts
to inform you about what's what's
interesting and what's not interested so
I have the piece of writing that I was
referring to I go a little bit deeper
their thing it's actually pretty
interesting
ten years ago it's not something I
really understood I've ever talked about
this publicly but ten years ago buddy of
mine named named Kip 2008 was living in
Chicago at the time he wrote a
handwritten letter to seven guys from
his life he was at the time I was in my
early 20s and he was about ten years
older than me so he's in his early 30s
around the same age that I'm 34 now I
might have been a little younger than 31
32 probably and he writes a letter it's
a seven of his friends handwritten
letter and he says hey what you each of
you don't you don't all know each other
but each of you are a really close
person from my life of a different phase
of my life it was like a college
roommate it was like the guy he sat next
to at his first job I has a really new
friend of his who just moved to Portland
at the time and like we had become fast
friends only there about six months and
there was seven of these guys and he
said but as we spread apart in our lives
and we start having kids and get married
and go these other places of our life I
realize we're gonna see each other less
and I'm afraid I'm gonna lose touch with
some of you but I love you dearly so I'm
gonna write you a handwritten letter
about what's going on in my life at the
very end of the letter he sent and I'm
actually getting goosebumps telling the
story cuz it's nice no story I've ever
told ya he writes a handwritten letter
note at the bottom he goes if anybody
wants to send a letter to the rest of
the other guys here's everyone else's
address you don't know each other but if
you want to send it just out in the
world
send it here's a CD to his other for his
other friends that these people don't
necessarily know don't necessarily
everyone like maybe knew one of the
other people because they're his group
of friends so maybe you've met a friend
of a friend but they're spread out
across the country I'm living Chicago at
the time not near any of these people I
only knew Kip and one of the other guys
and I was like this is a cool idea and
so the next month I
and this a handwritten letter put a CD
in the mail of the music I listen his
dates historic it was actually a burned
CD yeah I didn't send like a Spotify
playlist or something and I send it back
out to these guys what ends up happening
is every single month one of these guys
writes back a letter and it ends up
forming into this group it's been
through a few phases but it's this group
that we now call the fellas and what
happened is we added a few couple a few
other people over time and it's a
locked-in group but I honestly highly
recommend anyone doing this because it's
been one of those meaningful things my
life and I'll bring this back to why I'm
telling the story it's just a random
tangent but is that there's 12 of us
guys in this group the fellows and a lot
not everyone has even met everyone
although we do try to get together once
in a while but once per month we each
have a month now cuz there's 12 of us my
month is always December which is why
it's pertinent to the story and we've
made a lifelong commitment to one
another the lifelong commitment is we
are going to each share we've digitized
it it used to be handwritten but we have
we have a locked online forum blog you
can't see it but we have password to
sign in and we each send once per month
in a life update or a poem or just
something about our life with the idea
being that over the course of a full
lifetime commitment of sharing
vulnerably in kind of a men's group
format that this you know pieces of our
life will form this long-form tapestry
as we go through life together and now
it's been 12 years and soybeans people
will get married have their first child
you know career ups and down success
heartbreak you know losing parents you
know people getting sick whatever that
is or just joyful celebration sometimes
you know some will just write for the
month like yo I've been like really into
cooking and these are the five recipes
that I'm cooking it's not always like
this you know one intense thing but my
month was December and I finished my own
article crossing that I wrote the book
about on December 26 so the day after
Christmas and I'm sitting alone in my
tent for a few days waiting to
congratulate Lew Rudd on his crossing as
well as waiting to be picked up in the
airplane and I sit down there and I
realized it's my month for the fellows
post and I've always been it's a super
vulnerable forum to be able to share
openly with this group of guys
and so I sit there and I write this
piece that says the six things I learned
the most about the most important six
things that I learned about in
Antarctica and the top of lungs I
mentioned it our before was infinite
love this connection to this resident
resident resident resident energy that I
experienced out there and this peak
experience of just infinite love and
compassion and empathy and joy and this
flow state that I experienced and the
next was the importance of Jenna in my
life the next was the importance of
family and I was so grateful to this
forum that I had with these guys because
although I've been journaling avidly
throughout my life it was just like it
happened to be
it was my month and it was the due day
and I'm really big on not missing
deadlines and so I sat in my tent and
wrote my vulnerable fellows post out to
this other group of 11 guys a 12 of us
total and that piece of writing although
it's not explicitly in the book actually
formed the bedrock of what I wrote this
book about because it was just my truth
and the purity of that moment and the
experience that you and I had together
in that townhouse just you know a week
later or whatever it was and the stories
I was tell not I didn't think I'd put
the dots together at the time but the
stories you told me heard me tell
vulnerably were derivative of taking
that moment to actually kind of I don't
know sit with it and think about it and
write so distilling out you know what
was most important yeah and what's
beautiful about it for me was that I
guess why it's a sacred piece of writing
for me that ultimately poured my heart
and soul into the book itself was that
the forum the format of the fellows is
this sacred space where none of the
writing it's not narrative it's not like
let me show you the highlight reel of my
life it's not it's not necessary
implicitly bad or good but it's raw like
the point of the fellows and what Kipp
did when he sent this letter out to all
of us in 2008 was unknowingly he opened
up this space and a lot of these guys
aren't guys that are you know maybe you
know in men's groups or doing men's
works are doing ceremony or stuff like
this you know there's a pretty like you
know normal cross-section of you know
amazing human beings but you know as you
know as men and in our culture often
times pretty gardened and it's become
this really steak and se sacred space
and the post are never shared it's not
like anyone could ever see it so I know
that the writing that I put down there
was just coming was pouring out of my
heart with purity and it was so
important for me as we talked about the
editors and different people in the room
or other people sharing ideas I think
your book might should be about this or
that or the other thing to have this
anchor point to go I wrote this down and
the pureness and the authenticity of
this experience and I want to make sure
that the end product which I'm proud it
does is reflective of those emotions
that that those themes are what infused
this and breathe life into the narrative
yeah absolutely that's beautiful man I
love that that's a very like rare thing
to be able to maintain that level of
connection especially its guy and it's
beautiful it's like it kind of developed
organically and then there was kind of a
line in the sand moment or not in a bad
way if it was just like if you're in
you're in this is a life like an
explicit right this is a commitment
anybody like mr. macho or like you know
people now you're out no one's ever
missed it the from the first year one
guy felt the commitment was too much and
bad and rightfully so just said you know
this isn't for me and and the 12 kind of
callous won't we've had the 12 locked in
around it it's been we've been there the
whole time on this journey together and
it's it's funny because we're 12 years
into this kind of art piece or this
project together and it's a really I'm
an impatient person as you can see I
wrote a book in a there's a calendar
you're like I've gotta get this out I
got to get this down on paper but for me
it's actually one beautiful things in my
life to go like oh we're twelve years in
this project and like we're just getting
started like I pictured these moments
sitting around with these guys decades
from now and you know readin posts from
the the go the good old ought member
back in 2009 when you wrote this or that
you know and it's 20 50 or whatever if
we're fortunate to continue to live
healthy lives it's the private digital
forum version of Richard Linklater's
Brotherhood I thought you were gonna
tell me that all 12 dudes showed up at
that town house no no none of them
they're in it and no I've you know I've
I've I've been in person with all of
them the twelve of us actually heard not
brother
the the 12 of us have actually never
even been all in one place together
think eight or nine is the most we've
had we try to get together every year
every other cup here but it really is a
more than anything a kind of a writing
Club and of course we're in touch but it
is it's a beautiful thing it's a
beautiful thing in anyways I would would
love anyone to a copy the formax it's
been an amazing experience in my life at
school yeah well I would say that's one
of at least three Ohana's that you know
yeah you're a hot Ohana your family
family you alluded to earlier I would
consider that a certain kind of Ohana
yeah and then we have this other Ohana
that likes to be rowed across
stormy waters right so how does this
hold Drake Passage let's break this down
how does this whole how does this whole
thing come together yeah so the project
that I just completed Christmas Day of
this past year so a few weeks ago really
not even a month ago
it's just coincident that the possible
first solo crossing misprint on December
26 and then this Drake row would happen
364 days later we finished on that but
the objective was as a team to see if we
could be the first team to row a boat
across Drake Passage so that's from the
southern tip of South America starting
at Cape Horn in a tiny little rowboat so
no motor no say oh nothing 29 foot Robo
about 29 feet long I mean 460 rowboat
that's pretty big because you think of a
rowboat you know like a dude and a lake
it's not like a seafaring vessel no no
no you look at that you're like I don't
want to see 40-foot swells in that thing
let me tell you I did see 40-foot swells
man it was pretty freaking scary but the
that was the objectives and then to row
that boat all the way to the Antarctic
Peninsula which is a cross Drake Passage
roughly you know six seven hundred miles
and Drake Passage is known as kind of
the most ferocious waterway in the world
because it's the convergence of the
Atlantic the Pacific and the southern
ocean all kind of get funneled together
through this Drake Passage and as of
course as you get close to an article
you're looking at icebergs you're
looking at you know huge swells you know
freezing cold water
one degree Celsius or 333 Fahrenheit I
mean it's literally close to us for you
as you can get and the the goal kind of
came together so the the project itself
had been kind of a little bit in the
dreaming for a long time by this guy
named fian Paul who is pretty like your
captain yeah so he's no it is it's
worthy of noting that I have never wrote
about anywhere in my life listen I just
interject one thing here like when you
were back in Portland like training with
your trainer yes like McAskill you're
doing these crazy exercises you kind of
put it out on social media like guess
I'm getting ready for a big expedition
I'm gonna let you know in t-minus five
days or whatever and you'd be doing me
and you're like what do you think it is
people are saying crazy stuff but I was
like there's a lot of core going on here
there seems to be like a lot of lat work
I'm like this is this definitely
involved some kind of water yeah you
know like cold water yes I think I said
you were gonna win sir you know yeah
the Arctic Circle or something yeah I
was pretty you were pretty close people
are guessing water that's one of the
funniest guest so I said I'm gonna give
someone an emoji trophy on the comments
of who gets the funniest one and one kid
said you're gonna try to eat at every
single Waffle House in the course of a
month which for those of you on the west
coast maybe don't know it but it's the
you know diner chain and the South East
even the southeast ever you seen Waffle
House and the funniest thing I saw I
posted that on social I said I was like
winner that's the most hilarious one
maybe I should take that into
consideration just kind of joking around
day later my phone rings random phone
number answer the phone we have a
thousand or 1100 different restaurants
are you interested actually trying like
maybe the next sex yeah I'm focused on
this roaming project right now it's
hilarious but but why this like why why
did you have your sights set on that so
a couple of reasons one was I I've
always been fascinated by the ocean you
and I both share the love of the water
we both collegiate swimmers and my dad
has been living in Hawaii for 20 years
or so spent a lot of time in the open
water
coastally but I've never been in the
wide open ocean never I've never known a
sailboat in the open ocean certainly
never been on a row
and so I've always just kind of been
fascinated by exploring that part of the
world which I haven't explored before
and then also the huh sea level and then
the other piece of it that was kind of
interesting for me was you know I had
this kind of curiosity or this thesis of
saying I have you know built up these
skills of people if you call them miss
you know swimming and then swimming in a
triathlon and took triathlon into
mountaineering and mountaineering into
polar travel which are all somewhat
different from each other but there's
somewhat of a through-line certainly
cold places or you know you know Everest
in crossing Antarctica or a lot closer
together than crossing Antarctica is to
rowing a boat across an ocean and I was
wondering if I could take that kind of
with this beginners mindset or a growth
mindset of saying is it possible in a
short period of time to on a master
would be if not a fair word but to be
good enough or strong enough at a new
discipline in a short period of time to
then take that too that's a you know
highest extreme and still be successful
and then also most of my other projects
clearly a solo Antarctica project is
this although like I said it's really a
huge team including Jenna and others
around me to make these things possible
the athletic feat itself has always been
a solo experience as with swimming it's
you know your main triathlon yeah it's
been a pretty individual path for me you
know you swam on Stanford it's like
there's you know use the Stanford swim
team at the end of the day like you're
lining up swimming the 200 butterfly
it's you in the lane like swimming the
race you know and so for me it was
interesting to say like oh I wonder what
it'd be like to do a true team project
like that is also flexing and exercising
a different muscle for me in the
athletic space that of course you know
one hand when I was suffering from all
the solitude and Antarctica would have
been like god I've been great to have
some people around on the other hand of
course having six different people on a
tiny little rowboat in different
personalities from different parts of
the country whatever of course is going
to come with it some implicit challenges
and can we come together as a
high-performing team and be able to be
successful together so that was really
the intrigue for me was to kind of take
a lot of lessons from previous
expeditions but apply it in this a new
discipline of rowing something I never
done the ocean something I never done in
a team environment
something I never done to see if we
could be successful in doing that so
accomplished endurance athlete certainly
accomplished adventure athlete but never
a rower never right and so your your
your depositing yourself into this team
environment where like you know there's
an argument to be made that you're the
weak link like you're the least
experienced person in this boat right
because all these other guys are like
like vastly experienced ocean rowers and
collegiate rowers competitive rowers
yeah so it was interesting kind of I
don't mean that no like like so my first
four I want you to answer what you say
whatever gonna say but on top of that
like how are these guys you know taking
you in like oh we're gonna do this like
super hard thing that were potentially
putting our lives on the line and we got
this guy he's never wrote a bow before
all that so it's interesting so the you
know in the formation of the team so
Sophie on Paul who was very accomplished
you know the most accomplished ocean
roar in the world like the the rowing
version of what you did with the
mountain yeah so I mean he's the rowing
Grand Slam I'm not sure if that like
it's kind of a new thing that he's coin
he's the only person to have rowed and
now set records I believe as well on
every ocean so the Indian the Pacific
the Atlantic the southern ocean also the
Arctic Ocean so really really
accomplished his Icelandic I I've been
thinking about this project for quite
some time looking at the Drake Passage
as an objective and via another guy that
had been thinking about the project with
him would guy named Andrew town he we
went to college together so he wrote at
Yale when I swam there we didn't really
know each other in college but like
because we were kind of both there at
the same time had some mutual friends
and things like that and he had climbed
the seven summit so we're kind of aware
of each other had a few phone calls over
the years but like wasn't like oh my
buddy that I hung out with every day in
college or anything like that I'm so
pretty unfamiliar with him as well but
he calls me up right after I get back
from the solo crushing I finally did go
home and sleep in my own bed just after
I saw you in New York but the phone call
happened like I want to say like that
week or something like that and I get
this phone call from Andrew town and he
says like hey man I know you just got
back from Antarctica it's super cool
what you did there you know I'm kind of
brainstorming on another expedition like
wondering if you might be interested
like what is he's like you know to go
back to an article and a robo and I was
like delete my phone I was like I'm good
I'm not going back to an article but
then of course I got into thinking and
talking to them about it and kind of
what plans they had made and what you
know what was it gonna take to get there
and what we quickly realized of course
my interests were piqued as I thought
about a little bit more but also what
they had kind of come to me with it's
like a really interesting idea for a
project but these projects and what
Jenna and I and certainly I would say
what Jenna is exceptional at and the
couple call their people at work with us
now a guy named Blake Brinker whose
extraordinary at this kind of stuff as
well as problem-solving these produce
expeditions and it turns out that
actually the logistics to do this
project are really complicated so you
need this rowboat mean it's like
custom-built rowboat basically that's
like custom-built for all this cold
weather there are ocean rowing vessels
but we needed to actually have it like
retrofitted for like you know if we had
an iceberg and all this kind of crazy
stuff the only boat we could find is in
the UK that boat needs to be like
imported to southern Chile via the
Panama Canal but to be able to go to
Antarctica in a rowboat you can't just
like rock up to Antarctica in the
rowboat Antarctica for good reasons and
I hope it is always this way is one of
the most environmentally protected if
not the most environmentally protected
place on the planet
so one able to go there to get all this
permitting Antarctica is not an
autonomous you know country so you
actually have to apply for one of the
through the one of the treaty nations
and in this case we had to have a
supervising vessel which meant to have a
larger vessel with us not providing us
any support from the second we left
shore they weren't able to give us
anything or touch our string like that
but they provided the overall permitting
to allow us to be in Antarctica aren't
Arctic waters without creating all these
problems and that's like you know pun
intended I guess that's the tip of the
iceberg here with the complications of
this and so these guys have been
dreaming up this project but it was kind
of like but to pull this off not only is
it gonna be very expensive too
challenging to pull it off but this is
like a full-time effort of sort of deep
deep knowledge of how to run and
facilitate logistics and so myself but
really more than anyone Jenna and Blake
rolled up their sleeves and took kind of
took the CD I said said to feeling like
hey can we like run with this can we
like you know sink in and dig into this
and see like the feasibility of this and
they you know they worked on it
you know Jenna and Blake worked on it
you know all year long basically every
single day to pull together these
logistics and filled sanitation's
there's one thing I brought to the table
and the other thing was as you mentioned
Andrew town another guy John Peterson
who also wrote it was a captain the Yale
rowing team when I was there
incredible athlete like just absolutely
outstanding athlete collegiate athlete
etc but he's a college principal like
since being AK elite' or sorry high
school principal mmm all right yeah
school principes the one there's no plan
he wasn't Oakland high school might be I
can't remember it's a high school rumor
so he's a school principal um incredible
guy but admittedly he's like I was a
captain Leo rowing team I can put some
big numbers up on a rowing ugh he's like
but I've never been on an expedition
other than a couple hunting trips with
his dad he's barely you know you know
he's not been on big camping trips or
big mountaineering trips or big
expeditions or stuff like that so it was
interest like a Henley guy right and so
is interesting to say I never looked at
this team of you know maybe they looked
at me as the weak link maybe not I have
no idea it's neither here nor there
really it was that every single person
is coming together it's like fian
visionary of the project dreamed it up
knew everything about the ocean rolling
and realized that no one had ever done
this like amazing and obviously when
we're on the ocean he's gonna have some
really important skills but didn't quite
have the ability to facilitate actual
logistics of pulling off this large
scale of a project Jenna and I come in
and understand that have a lot of
relationships through been going to
Antarctica several times you have to be
the profile gender a lot of confidence
with the discoveries of the world right
100% yeah and the discovery got behind
it to do a big film project which was
cool we talked about that cuz was super
interesting to kind of have that
experience Jenna was on the supporting
or the supervising vessel throughout the
journey so she actually crossed the
trach as well as a whole other story
about that we can get into but then then
you've got these you know great rowers
but without the expedition experience so
it actually ended up being I got the
engine this yes it was like those guys
can crank but like when the swells got
up to 40 feet and they're wet and cold
and sleep-deprived so we were rowing 90
minutes on 90 minutes off the entire
time cuz we had to keep the boat moving
the entire time you know that was new
water for them because these guys used
to crank in on a rowboat for five
minutes or something like that and
that's like a max effort so it was
really cool too I mean it was
challenging
of course but ultimately really cool to
see everyone and cuz every single person
really brought something exceptional to
this project and we were definitely
stronger as a collective whole than we
would have been separately yeah I mean
on paper you look at it and you're like
this could either work really well
because everyone's bringing their own
unique skillset to this equation and
that could make it sing and make it make
the sum much greater than the sum of its
parts or it could just be a total
disaster
like in reading about this it's like you
guys didn't it's you know the press says
not a single argument like how is that
possible like you you're facing these
crazy obstacles and these swells and
everything you know that we can get into
about what happened during the crossing
but to be able to maintain your
equanimity in your composure and to you
know make sure that you're communicating
effectively and all of that to like get
through this that's pretty amazing yeah
I mean it I mean they're definitely
inevitable you're gonna have some
tension points or just tense moments not
in this or interpersonally but like we
got out in some pretty bad storms I mean
there was a couple times when the swells
were 40-foot high certainly for me that
was pushing the edges of my comfort zone
for sure and one of the things that was
interesting is that a lot of people you
know the the supervising vessel that was
there with the permitting and stuff and
also was housing the Discovery Channel
film crew that was filming the entire
thing which was really cool because we
were able to share this in real time in
social media basically as it was
happening you could tune in from you
were in Australia I guess and you were
like oh I'm warming the summer in
Collins you know freezing wet and cold
in his time though we had show text
beforehand I was like have a good time
man I'm gonna be I'll be tuning yeah so
it was cool to be able to share that in
real time but what we quickly realized
is with you know some people I kind of
imagined and I can maybe in the back of
my mind even imagine it this way it's
like oh there's this other boat there so
if we capsized our flip over they can
just like come easily scoop us out of
the water and like I mean that's my
thought that was my thought like it must
give you that you could like you know if
you get into real trouble like you got
the boat right so that there's there's
two sides of the same coin one is these
guys in this boat that boat was our boat
the rowboat was called Ohana which is
you know but the word that's been really
special and throughout my life and not
my own word obviously a Hawaiian word
to mean family and that was the essence
of this project was the family the six
of us coming together but also their
boat was called the Braveheart and that
was the boat that Jenna was aboard the
entire time as well as the film crew and
the Braveheart crew came pretty pretty
obvious to me the second we got out
there that yes of course in an extreme
emergency we wouldn't have been alone
there would have been another boat there
and would have done their very best to
help us
they had a zodiac on board they have a
life raft on board stuff like that they
never touched us and never taught us any
support and so we did a complete it
without taking any support from them
throughout the entire time but worst
case scenario they would have been there
however when I started looking at the
mechanics when I'm in this rowboat and
there's this huge boat next to me I'm
going like if that boat gets anywhere
near us it's way more of a disaster help
like 40 foot spell it's not you can just
like cruise up next returns like hey
guys come aboard like you're gonna be
they're gonna just get you know capsized
you even more and so there was like a
yes ultimately was it safer because they
were there I'm sure it was but there
wasn't like this easy exit strategy like
we might try to like throw you something
and then we'll be here and we can call
in the coastguard you know whatever that
is and so it was certainly been if I'm
not trying to pretend like that wasn't
an extra safety valve but it wasn't as
simple it's like we have a crane and we
can just pull your boat out if something
happens in a massive storm it was like
you guys are gonna be in this storm and
things are gonna get crazy the boat
itself was our boat was built to self
right and so really our first line of
defense was get inside the cabins which
pretty much couldn't fit inside really
only five or six of us could get inside
we're like all spooning each other some
funny video clips of us like basically
lying on top of each other and let the
boat either flip or roll or get bashed
around these swells and the boat itself
and we tested it beforehand actually you
know hopefully comes back up upright and
self right so that was a that was more
or less than the first line of defense
is just hang on for dear life and hope
the boat comes back up right so in those
40 50 foot swell moments or days or
hours when look you're not gonna be
rowing through that right like you just
all hunker down and you're like well
just ride it out now it's gonna be down
here and let it pitch us however it's
gonna pitch us yeah so the a couple of
things one you know I'm new to seafaring
but also learned a lot through training
for this project and ultimately
executing it so when the swell is lined
up in the right direction
we actually there was a couple times
when just coincidentally it was like
we're basically on the southeast heading
and this you know 40-plus foot swell
we're going the right way charge we
could go with it yeah and it was like
wild it was like riding like the wildest
roller coaster of all time I felt like
going down Splash Mountain or something
like when you're a kid you're like fine
like slow like luge you can feel the
wave just like you're basically
essentially surfing these waves and
coming up over these swells and some of
the shocks that the discovery took from
the other boat you would like see us up
on the crest the wave and then a full
mean 29 foots not huge we see a full 29
foot sailboat or rowboat completely
disappear and the ocean can't see it at
all and then it would come back out and
the full thing disappear in your life
wow that gives you a perspective on how
big these swells were so that was a then
ah then one of the reasons this crossing
is as challenging as it is in a rowboat
compared to say crossing the Atlantic or
something like that
would be that not that safe crossing
Atlantic is easy but if you cross the
Atlantic from the east to west my
understanding is this well and the
predominant winds or the trade winds go
usually east to west across that yeah
whereas in the Drake Passage the wind
shifts pretty much every single day in
every single different direction so
there were several times when the waves
would either be side to our boat which
could easily roll us if we approach to
the waves or completely against us and
in those instances way way way too
unsafe to row at all and our only choice
was to but basically throw this thing
off our boat called a sea anchor for
those that don't know what that is
because I didn't know what it is before
I started rowing a boat was basically a
big parachute that fills with you know
sea water but it holds you directionally
into the into the swell so it would
actually point the bow of the boat into
the swell and kind of we couldn't row at
all but we would get inside these tiny
little cabins and hunker down now there
was three cents for a couple times yeah
so there was three seats for rowing and
there was three of us not rowing at any
given time so six of us but alternating
90 minutes on 90 minutes off the cabins
were tiny you know two people in one
cabin the bow cabin and then Fiona and I
were alternating in the stern cabin
because that had all the navigation and
the SATA and the radio and stuff like
that so him and I were the people on
that kind of
you know him as the captain and me as
the first mate you know kind of
operating those controls on our you know
alternating shifts and that cabin was
tiny for one person now when Fiona and I
had to get in there this one picture
this I super strapping Icelandic dude
like 6 foot 2 6 4 3 oh no he's tall he's
got you know he's really wide shoulders
you're like that's a guy want to help
row a boat you're like that's amazing
like that is not the guy that I want to
cuddle up with next to in a space like
the size of you know it's like 2 foot
tall and like 4 foot long and we're like
both in the fetal position curled up
next to each other and it's not like we
get in there we're like you know look
for the weather report when's the way
they're gonna turn uh check back in 22
hours and the boat just well why am i
I'm just bashing around smashing around
and he ran i Fiona and I just jammed his
wedge in this little cabin I'm just
hanging on for dear life you know
literally cuddling each other big spoon
little spoon the whole deal it was quite
an adventure I'm getting claustrophobic
seasick thinking about it and I want to
get into like the sleep stuff and you
know the you know how do you poop and
all that kind of stuff everyone wants to
know about but one thing I want to point
out and actually didn't realize this
until this morning when I was kind of
looking into your expedition a little
bit more in depth the day before you
guys push off a Chilean c-130 disappears
with 38 people on it yeah I did not know
that yeah it was a really eerie and
obviously going across the train yeah so
we were staging our expedition in the
town of Puntarenas Chile we flew down
there early with you know we got our
rowboat through customs there and we
were doing you know packing the boat and
so we all arrived to puntarenas Chile
which is the same town that I actually
left for to go to Antarctica the two
other times I've been there for the solo
crossing and the Explorer screen same
projects so we stated out there
partially because Jenna and I have some
relationships down there that could help
facilitate that built up from the year
so it's made sense and also it's either
that or Russia why Argentina vehicon two
ports that you could imagine staging
this from to get down to Cape Horn so we
stayed at a puntarenas and the day that
we're leaving on the brave heart so
Braveheart takes us from Puntarenas and
actually takes us to Cape Horn the
actual starting point for the rowboat
we're all aboard the Braveheart we find
out about that day that
we're leaving that a plane crashed in
the middle of Drake Passage a c-130 as
you mentioned and that plane actually
had left from Puntarenas so a plane took
off basically where we are flying
towards Antarctica it was a Chilean
military plane and crashed in the middle
of Drake Passage and ultimately 38
people lost their lives which is you
know terribly sad terribly tragic and
then an interesting kind of chain of
events unfolded from there for us which
is you know after a year of Blake and
Jenna filling out all this permitting
you know all this requirements you know
dotting the i's crossing every T super
complicated process to get us to this
point we're driving south on the
Braveheart towards Cape Horn and Chilean
military boat pulls up right beside us
and you know contacts our captain asked
us to pull over and they board the ship
and they asked us you know what we're
doing what are we doing there what's
this rowboat thing you have like
attached to your outside of your boat
like what the heck is going on and you
know we talked to them and they
ultimately are like you do know about
this plane that just crashed right and
we're like yeah we're aware of that
they're like we're not sure that we can
let this project go we're gonna detain
not detain you in a bad way we're like
we need to divert you to our military
base so that was step one then eight
hours kind of out of our way to go to
this town called Porto Williams where we
had there's a larger military outpost
there of the Chilean military and then
our captain had to get off the boat and
meet with the Chilean military and
they're like look like all of our search
and rescue is diverted towards you know
doing a grid-like formation to find any
remnants of the plane or survivors or
any of this in the middle of Drake
Passage you can understand from our
point of view while we wouldn't want
someone else to launch seemingly kind of
dangerous expedition while their
resources are dispersed a hundred
percent help you and candidly obviously
as disappointed as I felt like wow we
planned all this stuff and now it looks
like we're not going to be able to go if
I'm sitting in the same shoes as the
Chilean you know military guy I'm
looking at this and thinking the same
thing I'm thinking like we can't like
why we you know allow this to go forward
and then the potential for - you know
gigantic disasters exactly act about
just right on top of each other so we
were there for a day about a day I guess
it was
and really a testament to the entire
team you know Jenna and Blake the people
who worked in the permitting forest
logistics and this is they kind of they
they're like okay
if we're gonna let you do this we need
to come on your boat and just do like a
top-to-bottom survey of what you guys
have going on
so we're come on we want to see the full
row but we want to see all of your
survival suits fian had designed these
custom survival suits for us that we
could row and these like bright orange
suits that we have these photos and
ended up being amazing I'm different
from the dry suits yeah yeah yeah so
this is the same thing I'm talking about
but usually a dry suit you won't be able
to row in it was like you really kind of
bulky and so he designed specialty with
all of his years of ocean knowledge
experience that's just special
custom-built suit that allowed us to
both row but have the safety of a dry
suit and they were like you know the
Trillium Ocho it's like okay well well
you've thought that through that's
interesting and then they see all our
flares in our eeper band all our safety
protocol and everything's registered
correctly and that like you know they
look up all of our resumes and they're
like okay like this guy is incredible
for this person's cross Antarctica you
know something guys haven't even
mentioned like you know Cameron Bellamy
is like a world renowned you know open
water swimmer
you know legendary of Horsham they're
cobbling okay okay like the crew is like
a legitimate group of guys attempting
this and then they do top to bottom on
Braveheart you know all their safety
protocols all this stuff and in the
paperwork that we had built with them
you know Jenna and them had worked
really closely together and actually
built this kind of dossier it was end up
being like a 30 page thing of all the
different safety protocols if a happens
B happens if C happens that you know all
these kind of things and so you know
fortunately for us certainly still
deeply tragic of the people who lost
their life out there but they took a
look at and they said you know what like
you guys actually you know have every
piece of paperwork you need you've got
the right resume you have all the safety
protocols you have the backup safety
protocols you know we're gonna let you
launch this boat so ultimately we were
only delayed by a day but it was a very
kind of you know nervous thing and also
just surreal and tragically sad for the
people at lost their life and the the
search and rescue that was going on yes
that was going on kind of all swirling
around you when I was pushed off right
did they recover any of the passengers
or um I'm not I don't think they found
any survivors unfortunately I know they
did find a few pieces of the wreckage
altum Utley but it was you know not that
much was recovered one of the other
interesting things that did happen that
was you know challenging for us as they
said we will let you launch this however
here is this air and they gave us four
weight points that basically formed a
square and said this is the grid where
we're looking for wreckage you notice
where boats and planes are flying over
and all this kind of stuff
and they drew it out on the map and it's
literally like the entirety of the whole
center of Drake Passage so like the
first Kundra dorso miles up at Cape Horn
we were fine but really quickly we're
gonna get into that space and they said
if you want to do this you can't come
into this area until we call off the
search and so when we did launch we kind
of had to just make the call of like hey
like we're gonna row in this direction
we actually changed our course on a
Western heading to see if we might have
to add distance to avoid this but we'd
know which way the current was going to
sweep we ultimately got lucky and the
the current and wind pushed that grid
area kind of you know further away and
we were able to continue our course but
even though just the first cup it's
almost like um you know you like you
know jump off and begin a project and
you just don't know if like you know
three days later yeah it's gonna happen
so two things I mean first of all why
would you sort of you know passing
through that area be problematic for the
search and rescue because they just
didn't want any other traffic in there
any other boats any other thing there
they were trying to spot so from
airplanes like oh my god what's that
little thing down there is that a piece
of wreckage is that a piece of the plane
just to like they're like stay we
probably should be letting you do this
anybody's if we're gonna let you do this
like totally understandable
second thing just problem you know a
mental perspective like alright we're
getting ready to do this thing and then
like this plane crash is you know and
thirty AP it's missing presumably dead
and you're like a day away from like do
it that's and from what I understand the
weather conditions were not that bad
that day right it was like it was
supposedly fairly clear so surprising
that was some some higher winds but it
was really unevenness that happen that
had to rent some crazy space in your
head Oh a hundred percent is anybody
like hey man I don't know like I might I
might be pulling out of this I mean it
definitely just gave us real
it gave us all pause I was
and I've heard Andrew and John reflect
on the moment when the Chilean military
boarded us and said hey this might not
go like at first and then Andrew and
John were telling me afterwards I can't
remember which one I think it was Andrew
was telling me this and he said he was
like you know really upset and bummed
but he realized in his subconscious he
was like kind of relieved like it kind
of said been like it's good you know
like and so the the captain of the brave
heart after meeting with the Chilean you
know was gonna come back we're having a
group meal and that's when he was going
to share the news and actually I had
kind of readied myself given the
circumstances for at best case scenario
they're gonna be like maybe in a week
try again and we were gonna run out it
we didn't have that time because we were
renting this big boat and we couldn't
afford to just keep renting it
indefinitely and he basically he comes
in and he's like I've got good news for
you we're gonna be able to go and Andrew
said to me that it was that moment that
he was like oh we have to go just once
you once you mentally check out a little
bit trying to get back into that totally
an ultimate game headspace my Andrew was
an absolute amazing super strong and God
his mind and body right but a momentary
moment of like oh oh wow this is this is
real and it does I mean you know people
of course in looking what I've done and
you know obviously I'm not gonna sit
here and say what I've done is the
safest choices in all the land I try to
prepare I try to plan I try to put the
safety protocols in place around the
things I'm doing but there's some you
know implicit risk in the activities
I've in part and you know after the
Antarctica crossing the solo crossing
you know people said to me they were
like you've done this set the speed
record on seven summits you've done some
of these other things like you think
you're good now like don't be like don't
try to be the next Evel Knievel and like
keep like one up in this and that's
never been my desire to just like do
stunts or feats or anything like that
but as this was unfolding I'll be honest
in my own in eärnur dialogue was like
this is this a step too far like Drake
Passage Robo you know this idea of doing
something I've never done you know
ultimately we know how it turned out
it's positive is able to achieve it but
you know
I have moments of doubt and my internal
dialogue was definitely triggered a
little bit in that moment of kind of
like wait a second wait a second is this
madness is that when you you know turn
to Jenna and say like is this are we on
the right class here
so Jenna said to me it might not been
right in the moment but within the last
you know day or so before launch there
had been a lot of actual I mean there
have been a lot of challenges and
getting this thing to launch and just
just complications just with you know
the the column bars that I used in
Antarctica the special bars by the way I
was entirely vegan the entire row talked
about it but I was I was entirely vegan
the whole row the column bars which are
kind of specialty bars that my sponsor
standard process created for me and this
time for the entire team those got stuck
in Chilean customs and we couldn't get
them out and like our food wasn't gonna
arrive there you know a number of things
happen with like packing the boat and
getting the boat and logistics and
people's flights delayed and like all
this kind of stuff and then this plane
crashes and general looks over at me and
she says it's kind of this interesting
moment where she's like well this is one
of two things that's happening right now
there are so many red flags and this is
the final red flag actually telling us
you know what
pack it in hmm get on a plane go home go
spend Christmas with the family like you
know enough it's enough she goes it's
either that or the eternal optimist that
she is or it's a stacking of all of
these obstacles overcome and this is the
final one to overcome before being able
to kind of be set free and do this
journey and she kind of asked me which
one you think it is and knowing the
difference knowing the difference is is
the difference between life and death
honestly like that's so tricky right
because it can go either way it's like
look all the evidence was there the
universe was trying to tell you man
write it with the heat you know that
volume dying all right I just crashed a
plane yeah like what else do you need to
know about why this is a bad idea or
like hey man life is about like
overcoming these obstacles when they get
thrown at you and yeah can you just can
you maintain that level of focus yeah
yeah and I mul tomorrow that we are able
to come to
gather and stick together and the team
on the rowboat sucked together the
Braveheart team was amazing Jenna's
supervising role from the Braveheart you
know worked out but it was hard-earned
and some of these you know circling back
on the concept I said and you know
whiteboard into reality or something I
read out on them in the book
it's amazing to talk about the epic
adventure the 40-foot swells or being
alone in Antarctica what it felt to be
pulling a 375 pound sled you know 12
hours a day alone across Antarctica you
know those are the you know edge of the
seat moments here and I of course love
experiencing them and I love talking
about them but there's a place that's
maybe a little bit less sexy between
writing the idea on the whiteboard and
actually executing on your dreams and
it's like toiling in those moments of
that grind and then not always as
high-stakes as you know what we're
talking about here but it's like are you
willing to just keep putting your head
down when you know Oh to get a chilly
boat in the Chilean customs you need
these 17 pieces of paperwork and this
thing lot of bureaucracy no you're like
what are you willing to sit there
filling out a fill that out like you
know like that stuff's not sexy and no
one ever wants to it's not cool to talk
about necessary whatever like that is
the dad is the difference between
dreaming up to something versus dreaming
up and actually doing the thing is being
able to put all of those steps together
and just knocking out those little
things one by one because when you look
at it from 10,000 feet or somebody just
randomly happened upon your Instagram
stories during this it looks like oh
he's some kind of you know you know
Richard Branson billionaire guys got
money and he's gay and he's got this
boat and it you know it's really hard to
to see the reality of it because the
grandeur is what you're kind of smacked
in the face was right right yeah and I I
mean I I love storytelling just in
general but I think that something I
often point to is the the NBC coverage
of the Olympics it's like I don't know
all the sports and Olympics I love the
Olympics but you may have seen in the
book Pablo Morales your college teammate
put a really significant role inspiring
like I to me when I was a little kid but
you know you turn on it's the fencing or
something like that and you're like I
don't know anything about this but you
get this backstory of actual guy and
it's his village back home training for
this and all of a sudden like you're
engaged in that
and it's not just at least for me when I
look at high performance in sports as
I've gotten closer and closer and lived
- at my own life as much as I loved
seeing the guy sprint the hundred meter
dash and win the gold medal with his
hands in the air whatever I look at that
and the first thing I think about is not
that you know 9.6 seconds or whatever it
just took him to run that race I'm like
huh I wonder like what was that journey
like where was the first race where was
the time he broke his ankle where was
when no one cared when was then he lost
the race to his you know the best guy in
his high school and he came back again
you know what is that entire process
where was the people in his life that
said you can't do this you're not gonna
do this those quiet moments alone full
of doubt full of fear but what was it
that made him get up when his alarm went
off the next day at 5:00 a.m. and get
out to the track because that is
ultimately what is manifest in this you
know 10 seconds and there is it there
isn't one athlete in that situation that
doesn't have an incredible story and you
know that that led them to that point
and NBC does an incredible job of you
know finding the best of those stories
telling them well and that's what that's
what like lights that Olympic spirit
totally you're like cuz now you under
it's like I don't follow fencing but if
you tell me that story like I'm all in
you know like I'm a hundred percent
there for that person yeah
so it's so like infectious I love that
stuff and I you know not not an NBC
documentary by any means but certainly
through the book it's like it's not just
like let me talk about 54 days cross
Skynyrd's let me tell you about the
totality of the life and experience and
the mentors and the people that you know
cuz I mean I think that that's the the
things I've read and the things that I
watch and things that I consume if they
don't have the fabric of the reality of
the journey and the story then well
you're not you're you're a natural
storyteller and I knew that when I was
in that townhouse and you had just
gotten back from that experience and you
told this story so well you had such a
command over you know what that
narrative you know was and and what was
impactful about it and you've done that
in the book as well and you you really
do it on the daily on Instagram like
you're relentless like you're always
like making sure that you know you're
telling a good story you know it's not
just like a clip of this like there's a
story that's unfolding always you know
through these adventures that you're
having but and I was once again like I
was like
is he doing this on the like how is this
working there's no there's no like
self-service or internet in the Drake
pack you know passage yeah and you're
not allowed to like do anything with the
Braveheart but right so how is how did
all that so it was pretty cool you know
we're talking about storytelling and
that's something and I quickly alluded
to but I'm gonna double click on it
which is I have been so inspired by
other people's stories in my life people
have never met but that's reading a book
that's watching a film that's watching
the Olympics you know whatever that is
and so I've realized that one of my
great passions is you know in the
duality of pushing my body in these
extreme environments but sharing that in
a storytelling medium and now we have
the ability of social media and
real-time storytelling to bring people
into that story while what's happening
with the hope of having that ripple
effect of positivity we add you know
600,000 students are enrolled in my
nonprofit programs of stem curriculums
and they're falling along every single
day they're learning about science
technology engineering math building
scale models of the boat or learning
about weather or climate change or the
ocean temperatures Ruby on 7 - yes -
Evan - and we built these curriculums
but these students all of a sudden
they're there their mind is lit up
because like wait this is a real thing
that's happening right now it's on a
dusty textbook of something that
happened like way back when and that's
the power of storytelling or for me as a
young person I mentioned Pablo Morales
you know when I was seven years old the
1992 Olympics in Barcelona I was a seven
year old kid didn't have much money in
my family you know really kind of you
know basic childhood growing up my
mother was young when she had me so you
know she was a young mother and we have
a TV set and there's a TV set showing me
the Olympics you know halfway around the
world in this city called Barcelona
Spain that might as well been on a
different planet compared you know I
never traveled and when I was a kid and
I see this 100-meter butterfly and this
guy win this gold medal and it sparked a
fire inside of me my mom was like she
just said to me you know my mom's
incredible and her guide it she giving
me throughout my entire life including
with the burn accent which you and I
have talked about in depth but you know
she says to me she's not like oh that
was this cool thing we watched on TV she
was like that inspired you like do you
want to join the local swim team like we
could do that and like shouldn't you
remember her saying
it's 1992 what's the peak age for a
swimmer in the Olympics and I was like I
don't know four men maybe you know we
went and looked it up and you know maybe
he's 19 or 23 or 20 I'm sure okay so
what Olympics might you be able to swim
at is it 2008 is it 2012 like my mom
walked me down the path but where I'm
going with that is the storytelling the
element of somebody sharing their story
NBC in this case sharing Pablo Morales
story with a seven-year-old boy sitting
in Portland Oregon changed the entire
trajectory of my life what I believed in
whatever and so with my expeditions I've
always done my best to share the stories
in real time and with this expedition in
particular as we realized the need for
the supervising vessel we all of a
sudden realized that we were gonna have
the best capability we've ever had to
tell a life story in real time and
that's when this amazing partnership
came to life with Discovery Channel and
they said we want to shoot this
long-form documentary of this thing and
we can shoot it from the Braveheart
we're like that's amazing but what about
in addition to that we invest in the
best satellite technology possible to be
able to be beam social media content so
as you're watching you know Instagram
stories of me getting bashed around in
my little cabin on Christmas Day or
arriving you know penguins jumping off
the side of the boat or all the things I
was able to just like capture with my
iPhone we could send that out or in
their case they created also 14 what
they called mid form episodes about five
or ten-minute episodes that you can go
see on YouTube or you can see the
long-form documentaries not out yet and
the same thing they actually had an
editor on board so the guys were
shooting editor on board
iridium partnered with us as well as a
satellite company to have like the best
most powerful satellite you still can't
send like a ton it's not like it's not
like you could just like you know beam
content like right and left is if a
normal internet connection but they
could get enough content out to share
these like little things and it was
really cool to bring that to life I mean
it took having a massive partner like a
discovery it took you know Iridium
believing in the project it took a lot
of different bigger pieces that were
able to pull together but ultimately it
gave hopefully the experience of like I
said there's six hundred thousand
students following along this visceral
real experience that just people who are
falling on my
so Graham and things like that a way to
connect with the story as its unfolding
and you know my hero is an exploration
are the heroes of you know a hundred
years ago and they'd go away for three
years you know a Shackleton or someone
like that and come back and maybe have a
couple really grainy images and their
journals the they could have transcribed
or something like that but and no
telling their story at the Yale Club
right exactly what is it about Yale yeah
ever but the thing about the thing about
now and trust me I think there's a lot
of things that are negative about social
media and I've you know had my
addictions and vices in the world of
social media and going down the rabbit
hole of a phone for sure and I see the
the pitfalls of it I do think to see the
beauty of it I do see the beauty of you
want to share stories at scale and
impact people in that positive way and I
know you do as well and it's a cool
thing I love that it all goes back to
Pablo I mean that's just that's
beautiful yeah you know I remember that
100-meter butterfly race in Barcelona
like I could recount every second of
that I've watched it so many times and
you know I was somebody who who who grew
up with pictures of Pablo on my wall as
a kid even though I'm older than you and
then had the opportunity to to train and
be a teammate of his at at Stanford and
I watched somebody who you know he was
the most dominant swimmer in NC to a
history I think he won like he won all
of his races at NC to a championship
it's up maybe one like we almost had a
perfect record Wow between 84 and 88 the
most dominant you know American swimmer
this goes into the 88 Olympic Trials
with the expectation that he'll not only
make the team but he's going to be the
captain of the team and whether he over
trained or had a bad day or whatever he
shows up at an Olympic Trials and he
doesn't make the team crazy it's the
craziest thing right so then he goes to
law school and swimming like that
there's no like oh wow you're done it's
like you didn't decide when the day he
didn't make one or top one or two in
your event her career is over
yeah so he goes the law school at
Cornell does two years at Cornell and
then decides hey I miss my family I've
got some family stuff I'm gonna go back
home for a while dips his toe back in
the water and it's like maybe I can swim
a little bit
you know start swimming a little bit
without any agenda it's like I feel
pretty good and decides to go for it
again man against all odds makes the
team in 92 and then wins the gold medal
this is a guy who is whose parents were
were immigrants from Cuba and whose dad
like very you know salt of the earth
people like the nicest people in the
world and and and Pablo is one of the
most humble people you'll ever meet for
being such an incredibly talented you
know athlete I mean when you watch him
swim it's like poetry it's just it's a
beautiful beautiful absolutely and when
he won that gold medal and they cut to
his dad in the stands it's just I can't
you know I cry every time I see that I
have and I mean I am sitting here as a
product of the guy who could have given
up in 88 who could have not gone back to
swimming and literally for me never met
Pablo Morales
but deep deep deep gratitude for him
continuing on his path and be able to
shine in the entire world and for me to
be able to beam that signal from the
other side of you know Europe into my
living room to experience that moment
you know as a little kid it certainly
changed my life and it's funny I didn't
you know when I first picked up your
book several years ago I had no idea
about any of the Stanford swimmer thing
but I didn't think of the the
orientation and I remember there's a
photo of him and you graduating from law
school together something in your show
then then we there's an so then I went
to Cornell Law School right I was there
while he was back training so like he
did two years and then I show up after
he stopped out right and then we did our
final year to go that's what it was and
so I remember when I read your book the
first time opening that in fact no way
ritual problem we're out like it's just
crazy how all those different kind of
tentacles
intertwine to be clear alright just so
there's no confusion when I was swimming
at Stanford you know they would like
skip through the coach was like alright
get in the lane with Pablo you know it's
like are he done I'm behind him just
watching his feet get further and
further ahead of me like it's not like I
was going toe to toe with this guy like
I could not train at his lab but you
were in the same Lane which is very was
and that's what I wanted that's what I
asked for
you know what's Pablo up to these days
he he has been
coach of the swim team at University of
Nebraska for quite some time cool yeah
that's awesome so he he graduate from
law school practice law for a little bit
was like this isn't for me and got the
head coaching gig at Nebraska he's been
there for a long time well if you ever
talked to him sending my deepest love
and gratitude for inspiring the seventh
of myself I love ya all right
how'd you poop how'd you go to the
bathroom
you must be reading the Instagram
comments certainly most asked question I
know I know the answer like you know
just in case there was no toilet
facilities on the boat there was no
amenities really of any kind on the boat
there's three seats on the boat for the
rowing there's what's called the stroke
seat which is by the stern cabin obvious
when you row you're facing backwards the
direction that you're going same as like
a rowing crew boat on on wanna river i
sat in the bow seat so I was sitting
towards the front of the boat
but the third person in the line if that
makes sense next to the bow seat we had
our fancy toilet literally one inch from
where I was sitting the entirety of this
expedition which lasted just under two
weeks we had a five-gallon bucket inside
that bucket was how we used the bathroom
so someone would say either me if I was
while I was rowing or you know the guy
Cameron or Jamie who was with two other
guys that I rode with they would say hey
man I got to the bathroom
get out of your seat I would get up I'd
switch into their seat you'd take care
of their business and simple as that not
glamorous but and just you just bailed
up the bucket out yeah be able to book
it out obviously not throwing any trash
into the ocean but the human waste went
over into the ocean and that's kind of
the standard protocol of that it's it's
not a lot of people want to know that
it's you know yeah we had to go to the
bath how do you think it's a bucket a
bucket simple as that so there was one
day where one of the dudes must have
been Cameron yeah it's swimming yes yes
and it looked like was he not wearing a
wetsuit no Cameron Bellamy is just a
legendary human being you would love
this guy I yeah he gosh what a guy he is
South African guy was in San Francisco
now he's rode for the national team of
South Africa
when he's I think he's 38 or something
now but wanting us on early 20s so he's
a really accomplished rower and then
later in life you can appreciate this
much later in life in his late twenties
maybe early 30s he got into swimming
like did wasn't a pool swimmer didn't
swim and you know you know how hard it
is from your trotters are people just
kind of learn how to swim like later in
life you don't learn well at a young age
yeah it's tough it's super tough and he
just got way way way into swimming and
so for the last several years he's
accomplished a ton in the world of ocean
water swimming so he's done I hope I
don't get this wrong but he's done like
whatever the ocean swimming Grand Slam
is so we strummed all the major channels
it's called something slightly different
than major big pastures the one in Japan
done that crazy story of some models
jellyfish stings and almost no wetsuit
always no wet - in a couple of those the
one I think the one between the Ireland
and the UK maybe is that one I might be
getting this wrong forgive me ocean
swimming community for getting it not
the details specific that one was like
free sinkhole that's like 50 degree
waters or something like that or low 50s
and you know Neil wetsuit on ocean away
yeah ocean swimming is is no wet suit at
the Vaseline Tana Vaseline on to then
what he did is he swam around the entire
circumference of Barbados which no one
had ever done that before and that was
last year and then this year while we
were training for the row he actually
was a lot more focused on a swimming
project that he was doing and he
completed what I believe is the longest
or certainly one of lungs might be the
longest open-ocean swim crossing ever
which was 57 hours straight from st.
from Barbados to st. Lucia he originally
was trying to do the cubital or to swim
but permitting and with you know the
stuff with Trump and the Cuban stuff
just kind of fell apart and so we
pivoted but it was a like a hundred and
a hundred and five miles something
something like that again I'm probably
going through these details a little
wrong but it was like exceptional and
the stories he has some that obviously I
wrote about this guy you know 12 hours a
day for you know two weeks I heard all
of his stories and cause that's an
incredible guy great spirit really
really warm person he's like he's got
like he was telling me every 30 minutes
he got so many rashes on his mouth from
being in the water for so long for 50
some hours
he's taking these gobs of Vaseline and
he's literally putting like hand fold
and fistfuls of a saline into his mouth
and it would like deteriorate with the
salt water and so we keep extra smeared
around his beard and he would like kind
of like suction it from his beard into
his mouth and then get another handful
of ass I mean it was like brilliant up
and he finished it which is
extraordinary of anything in up in the
hospital for a few days just because of
like the jellyfish stings and this but
talk about a guy who is a mental and
physical absolutely stallion so we're on
sea anchor this day day five or day six
or something like that one of days when
we had to wade out one of the storms
when the storms and the winds were
against us and we're getting ready to
pull up the sea anchor so the storm was
finally cleared enough that we think
it's we're gonna be able to row in the
next couple of hours so it's not huge
swells at the time but we're kind of
coming off an intense storm on the
rowboat and he's this renowned ocean
water swimmer at this point and he was
like hey Colin how cold you think the
water is and I was like whoa I don't
know it splashed across my face met
storm last night it was like you know
coldest thing ever like it's all
horrible no one was like wet and cold
splash in the face we're taking this on
and I was like I was like I know we're
not fully to Antarctica and I know
they're it's you know one degree so I
don't know like maybe maybe it's like 38
Fahrenheit or you know four Celsius or
whatever the conversion is like
something like that also kind of
something stupid cold right and he's
like he's like I think I'm gonna go for
a swim no I was like what and he's like
dude we're in the middle of a passage
man like you only live once man like
what am I ever gonna be back here like I
love swimming like I'm gonna swimming at
of course I was like I think he's
serious and I was like if you're gonna
do this let me grab my iphone filmed it
but second of all it's like but dude
think this through first because like
you got to get back in the rowboat
there's no like warming you up there how
is he gonna warm up warm there's no this
is like could jeopardise kind of all
this he was like he was like dude like
I've got it and I was like if you
believe in yourself bro like all four I
will be here cheering you on and so sure
enough
strips down butt-naked he puts his
second as I can't he brought a swim cap
and goggles which I didn't notice we
must have been thinking about this pulls
out his swim cap and goggles from the
base of his thing the South African flag
on his head goggles on nothing else
completely but naked
and just does a full gonna dive jumps
into the ocean you know swims around he
wasn't in there for a long time you know
maybe 30 seconds or a minute but plenty
long trust me I wasn't looking to go for
a swim there and so what a legend man he
swam in the boat rake passage that's
been one of the episodes that discovery
did I'm sure it'll be in the future like
how did he well so he gets out did you
get right into the dry suit like how
does it sound
yeah is he he must be like a big dude
with a lot of he's a big dude yeah he's
like 220 pounds like kind of broad you
know tall he put on some weight for the
rowing project specifically he's done
some other rows where he's lost some
weight so no he had some weight on it
means strong fit guy more than anything
like fat at all but I don't know man
he's just a beast like he's just he just
got out with like a big eyes kept
smiling the entire time he just gets out
like oh that was cool man like whatever
is we we uh you know had a Canada goose
as a sponsor so he chives in the bow cab
and wraps himself and a bunch of down
jackets and shippers a little bit and
he's like so we rowing let's go like
he's just ready to go it's a complete
Stav äj-- on the other side of that your
boy Andrew had a little trouble with his
ankle right yeah I'm in there I think
you're I think maybe thinking of Jamie
yeah so oh yeah it was Jamie yeah yeah
yeah so ya know he so we got these boots
and none of us had ever silly thing but
we actually hadn't tried them out cuz we
did a test row together in Scotland for
a day but it wasn't like super super was
wet and rainy and Scotland always was
like 55 degrees so we kind of researched
the best
ocean rowing or ocean boot that we could
find was for like cold water sailing and
we had none of us had actually ever
tried them on and before this row
because we just adore there's no climate
to actually truly test them in and all
of my mountaineering experience and
things like that always I try to test my
gear but this is like one piece of gear
there's no like opportune time to test
and there's no since no one's ever done
this before I wasn't like asking the guy
like so what boot did you wear when you
rode a boat across Drake Passage
so I got these boots and they just
started digging into his ankle like
super super super bad and I he never
mentioned it I mean God Jamie it was
amazing to be with a group of guys that
actually had
such an orientation towards positivity
because Jamie's that right in front of
me and then Cameron was written for me
the three of us were on our ship and
John Andrew and Fiona were on the
opposite opposite shift and Jamie's that
right in front of me so closest to me
and didn't say anything about it
laughing playing joking around whatever
it's like oh and finally one point is
like kind of like you know my ankle
hurts my you know you know I'm like
you're all right and he's like oh it
just kind of feels like maybe there's a
little blister or this or that finally
after like ten days or something like
that he finally takes off his boot and
shows somebody and he was like literally
like ripped off all of the skin all of
everything feet have been wet and cold
for so long when we were getting in the
cabinet on 90-minute downtimes myself
included we weren't like taking off our
gear we had these like these crazy you
know dry suits on we had these boots on
with this so we just be soaking wet and
just like lie down and try to eat
something real quick and get you know
get to sleep for a few minutes and so
he'd been doing the same thing that any
of the rest of us has but turns out I
mean I don't know how he got through it
but he had just ripped apart his ankle
and so when he finally pulled it off it
was yeah I read that I was down to the
bone
yeah it was it was pretty it was pretty
hard to like not say anything yeah and
like it wasn't like he didn't say
anything but then stopped rowing or
didn't say anything of this like he rode
the entire time with you know a smile on
his face and this I mean he is a he's an
interesting lineage his grandfather
actually was the first person to fly
over Mount Everest in a fixed plane in
like the 1930s and those photographs
were actually used to help Sir Edmund
Hillary on the initial climb he's from
Scotland
Jamie SR just interesting story with
kind of exploration in general and his
family lineage but but yeah somehow I
mean he was just like locked in and was
like oh my ankle hurts love it like me
the one time I heard of it and like bro
like just like a could someone help me
rip 20 minutes in like this boot doesn't
feel good what was the gnarliest part
like was there ever a moment where you
thought you were just you know over your
head here literally figuratively to me
there were two moments I mean there's a
lot of moments but I've had to like kind
of circle on you know to really kind of
full-on moments one was the first like
major
Dorman wrote in and for me it was you
know a I'd never been in the open ocean
like that and all the sudden like it's
three days in a three or four days I
camera exact day they kind of all blend
together since there's 24-hour non-stop
of rowing weird sleep schedule but just
massive swells kicked up like I said
that feeling of like riding this
rollercoaster it's like fun for a little
bit and then I remember this moment so
John and I John was the school principal
we would switch the same seat as each
other like he was always in the back
seat on the opposite chef and I remember
the middle of this storm and to get to
my seat is like you know just like
getting jostled around just like
switching into my seat you think I'm
that's when he could easily fall off the
ball that we were clipped in with a
safety line and John looks over at me
and he's also you know amazing row or
like I said but he's not been in a
massive storm like this either and he
kind of looks at me with like this
death-defying look and he's like he's
like how do we get out how do we make
this stop you know and I was like I
think we just keep rowing it was just
got Moe's moments of just like
inarticulate but like I think it was a
the subtext was I'm afraid I think the
only way to stay safe is to keep rowing
or key part the boat from turning and
getting rolled over in this and so that
was a race you're like growing but it's
it's not exactly making you go forward
no and it's like building and the swells
get built right so it's like oh this is
getting back oh this is pretty big oh
this is really big oh is it gonna keep
getting bigger like this and the
craziest thing happened in that moment
which is ultimately kind of joyful and
reflection but it was bizarre it was
this Matt and storm really cloudy and
you know gray and it was getting dark
there's not a lot of darkness but we're
a little bit further north we had about
two or three hours of darkness in the
first week or so and it was you know
getting getting towards dark or dusk
anyways and all the sudden this huge
cruise ship comes like out of like a
ghost ship out of this and we hear this
at first we have Frakes are like oh my
god it looks like they're coming like
straight Boris they don't see us
thankfully they actually have been
tracking the project and it was a cruise
ship that was like taking you know
passengers to the Antarctic Peninsula
and they came by to like we heard that
there's these crazy knuckleheads you
know rowing a boat across Drake Passage
and they came to like check us out so
we're in the middle of this storm kind
of like hanging on for dear life John
are like how do we get out of this all
of a sudden there's a cruiser planes
people on vacation and people are on the
deck and like dressed in these all these
nice coach they're just waving and
they're like hey sorry I feel like I
should just started crying in this boat
and I'm not sure why I'm just the kind
of pure like strange bizarre scared
happy elated the juxtaposition it was
just super weird and then the other
point the other piece that for me
actually was the absolute scariest part
of the entire expedition was the very
last day we are we're getting close to
an article so there's outer islands of
Antarctica actually that are off the
peninsula and so about a hundred miles
from our finish point we wanted to
finish on the actual continent of
Antarctica on the actual true landmass
on the peninsula
there's outer islands and so we finally
approach those when we saw land it was
amazing I hadn't seen land for you know
12 days or 11 days or whatever it was
and was like oh my god there it is
there's just you me Erica particularly
I'd never seen um you know the peninsula
like this and it's just you know all the
sudden you've got icebergs jutting out
you've got you know tons of sea life
penguins you've got these huge mountains
it's just like I have a dream landscape
there's amazing to see that after not
seeing anything for so many days and we
still have a hundred miles to go so it's
kind of like we're here oh we're not
here because we still have taro for like
a day and a half and the weather is
actually looking like it might turn and
all these things so we keep rowing and
finally we were thin about you know
remember when maybe eight hours from you
know proposed that we were maybe like
within 20 miles or 15 miles or something
like that the finish and the weather is
not great and what's happening is
there's basically there's big icebergs
you know there's some big massive
icebergs which are a little bit easier
to steer around but there's also some
smaller pieces of ice and things like
that and obviously we don't want to
damage our boat right at the end and
this is kind of one of the trickier
spots so what was happening
Fiona and I were alternating each other
being in the stern cabin you know with
the navigation we had a rudder that we
could like control we could put on a GPS
or we could like do it manually and so
we were communicating which everyone
wasn't rowing would be like okay even
though our course would take us towards
that iceberg turned ten degrees to the
right or turn ten degrees to the left or
whatever and it would kind of like could
we be able to steer around it because
you can't see where you're going because
you're rolling backwards right and so I
have been doing that and this time we
were also sleep-deprived it was like
4:30 in the morning we hadn't slept in
so long and I had been like trying to
steer while him so I'm not sleeping
during my shift cuz I'm trying to help
steer then all of a sudden we start
going meet Cameron and Jamie on our
shift we're rolling were rolling running
now we're like you know five hours away
from the finish we're kind of getting
pretty excited and we're kind of putting
a lot of power and orders is kind of
cranking on it and whatever and then all
this studying we hear the alarm of the
Braveheart the supervising vessel just
go as loud as possible and we're like oh
my god like what is that like so an
emergency like on their boat and thank
God like Jamie looks over his left
shoulder and we're like 10 feet away
from a massive iceberg and I'm talking
like I mean you say the tip of the
iceberg is you know like you know 90% of
its underwater but even what was above
water was like you know god I don't know
like three four stories high and like a
hundred foot wide and I can just see
this whooshing current just kinda like
sucked underneath it in the bow which we
were jamming to Andrew and Cameron are
like blissfully asur John Cameron - John
and Andrew like blissfully asleep and
the cabin is like we smashed into that
this iceberg just gonna crash the front
of our boat and like just split it in
half and all of a sudden it was like
we're trying to paddle reverse in the
other direction so how does he come up
on you so quickly though I mean I know
you thought you're not you're looking
backwards but like something that large
it's two things we're just a little
nowhere yeah so we're two things one is
that Theon had fallen asleep and like
again we were delirious and there's none
not me pointing to blame like he had
like we're gone at all like in and out
of this like weird consciousness and was
like I mean I'd fallen asleep for a few
minutes and no looking out there and as
well as you were just we're just locked
in so worth going backwards and again
was probably our fault as well as like
not you know we had some mirrors that we
actually could try to see but they were
like fogged up it was just kind of a lot
of things conspiring but also more than
anything it would be what I would say it
is so easy to let your guard down
towards the end of an expedition you're
like we've made it like we're in
Antarctic waters whatever and a similar
thing falls flat totally and the a the
interesting parallel my own life I did a
crossing of Greenland when I was
training for the Antarctic expeditions
you know month-long crossing 400 miles
of Greenland and I got to what was my
last day my last night I'm I go tomorrow
I'm gonna complete this or I'm gonna
finish this and get out of here gonna
get picked up and leave
I'm 27 days in and find the entire time
and that night I go to bed and every
single night I had been diligently
pushing around to find crevasses or
things like that make sure I didn't set
up my tent in the wrong place wherever I
go it's my last night whatever but not
here in Greenland lessons happened I
said at my getting ready to set up my
tent always kind of stuff taking my tent
out of my slide it was calm weather so I
wasn't like too worried about stuff
blowing away I just kind of like let my
guard down all the sudden boom fall
through a crevasse all the way to my
shoulders I put my arms out and catch
myself and I looked down and my entire
body is hanging over two hundred feet of
nothing underneath me high fallin in
this crevasse like no one's finding me
down there I don't have my staff won't
have any of my gear like nothing
fortunately literally up to my shoulders
I you know grab myself arms completely
up over deck and was able to pull myself
out no laying flat on the snow and the
ice and it was you know a close call and
nothing tragic happened but it's you
know an inch from failure in that moment
and it's another example I guess I
should have learned the lesson the first
time and did not have to learn it again
on the trach but it's like so easier
like I'm nearly there great or like last
few hours of rolling this like two more
shift let's just put her back into it
whatever like smash into an iceberg like
just so close and stuff like that so
yeah it's a definitely a good lesson and
that was that was that iceberg moment
was definitely a scary one the scariest
moments you know period so 12 days 600
miles how many miles was it so it's hard
because I think the crossing is defined
specifically the distance we did in a
straight line was 650 miles but I saw
the map attacking all over that like
yeah so I think we actually rode
something more like 750 whatever bad
the classification of the record and
ultimately I think there were six World
Records in three world first associated
with the crossing and derivative records
I'm each other I don't pay too much
attention to little granular details of
that but the way that the ocean rowing
society which is a world that I'm
actually not that familiar with
obviously they calculate it just what's
the straight-line distance Oh straight
line distance 650 miles I think we're
owed something like a couple of times
then sinker we got blown back like 15
miles then rode forward and to the side
with the winds and currents and stuff
like that so far enough so you finish
and in another stroke of marketing
genius you pull like a copy of the book
come on that is unbelievable and you're
like you got me laughs I was like that's
pretty good my ration riding you brought
a couple copies I brought three copies
they're actually the advanced reader
copy so they weren't the final draft and
they actually say published eight one
twenty eight twenty which you know they
moved the publication date up so there's
three copies we're doing a pre-order
campaign anyone who prayer at the book
was entered to a win one of the signed
copies that actually came to drakes my
book about Antarctica returned to
Antarctica and of course we had to take
a photo and she tried out in the world
of course man who won those copies some
amazing people yeah there was uh they
got caught spread around this a really
really cool girl name and nez gal Michi
I was like I'm so about the names right
I think I mispronounced them
she had one we you know everyone that
sent in to this email address that we
set up got entered in the contest with
the pre-order and then we did a random
drawing from that but was really cool
you know some people that one had just
kind of written something and they're
like oh hey like this and you know email
back and forth and she had a really cool
story that kind of touched my heart she
said her and her brother her brother had
started following me like I saw my aunt
Arctic crossing last year and she had
never heard of this but he kind of came
home every night and was like really
like talking about this over their
family holiday except goin sided with
Christmas and the holidays and stuff
like that and you know she felt feelings
a little bit disconnected from her
brother she said and that like really
brought them closer together just kind
of having this thing to check in with
every single day and talk about and all
this kind of stuff so she enter
for the drawing so that she could give
it as a gift to her brother and so it
was super cool and they want another
another guy this this touched me his
name was uh I think it's Dave goetzmann
I remember because it Instagram handle
was the at the underscore goatman I
think he's like ultra runner cement that
in New York State but he you know most
people were sending in like Amazon
pre-order links and stuff like that
which is awesome great a normal way to
preorder a book for sure but you can
also proo it of course on independent
booksellers in other places around and
that's where all the books is sold and
he and he live in Lake Placid in our
local bookstore and so he had called up
the local bookstore at a pier of the
book the local bookstore which which
touch me I was like oh well my book is
you know in the small bookstore in Lake
Placid so that's a new experience for me
I suppose you've experienced that
yourself seeing your own book and other
places that was new for me and he had
said he had sent this funny you know we
swear any selected email we opened the
email just to check to make sure that it
had like the right you know actually
period of the book and whatever so we
could send him the prize and he had sent
like a text message chain and like a
picture of a receipt from this little
bookstore and he was like does this
count like I just want to make sure like
this is actually the pre-order but from
like a you know like a handwritten
receipt and whatever it was totally
legit he actually did a pre or the book
but I just thought it was cool that you
know he went to these like local shop
and it was in there as well so there's
some amazing people wanted I was just
grateful for the love and support around
the book and it's you know just just
getting out into the world now their
last five days or so so it's just I
guess it's just beginning but so you're
doing the thing you're in New York
you're you know doing all the shows and
all that kind of stuff and most of that
stuff is you know the five minute you
know thing you're kind of in you're out
they ask you the same question what's
next and all of that what do you think
like like you ever leave those
experiences thinking like like I wish
they'd ask me this or what isn't you
know here's what I think people are
missing like do you think you're ever
like misunderstood or is there anything
that like you feel like you wish you
were asked more but it doesn't come up
or like where are people like not
connecting in the way that you want them
to
I mean I will say this now and this is
not just lip service because I'm sitting
here in front of you because I've told
you this in when you and I have spending
time in private when you and I are
climbing you know 29 Oh 29 together Utah
this summer or you know the other times
you spent this that I genuinely think
and the cover of outside magazine
calling you the Oprah of endurance
sports I think is actually very apropos
because you are an extraordinary
interviewer and actually go in extreme
depth so I've been humbled to be a guest
on your show and I think the question
although I know you weren't asking it in
a self-serving way at all but I
genuinely think you were just
extraordinary exceptional at this and
it's a gift it's a beautiful gift of
your insight and your presence with all
of your guests I have been not just a
guest but a massive fan of your podcast
for a long time but I appreciate that
that was not but I think that is like
when you if you're gonna talk for two
hours totally totally but what I do
think and I think particularly around
the book that I do you know I this book
is a harrowing tale like it is me raw
there is some crazy things that happen
out there that I had you know never
really you know spoke super open there
at least super in depth about about this
story and I wanted to be raw and real
and I wanted it to read in a way that
kept people's attention so I you know
hopefully and certainly the feedback
we've gotten is that it's page-turning
and it's engaging it's it's not a how-to
book it's not a prescriptive you know
self-help book by any means it is a you
know edge-of-your-seat type of book but
sometimes in these interviews like that
quick you know you know three-minute
four minutes pause I'm grateful for that
you know attention I do think that
people want to like they're like so
we're here with adrenaline daredevil
crazy you know thrill seeker Colin o
Brady I think um even the headline on
the Today Show which was so cool to be
on the tatio and be able to share this
when the book launches but I think then
they put it up online it said like
daredevil Colin Oh Brady returns from
whatever and to me that does a little
bit missed the point of what's going on
here I think that I'm going out in the
world and obviously pushing my body and
you know trying to strike stretch limits
of my own potential out in the world but
there is so much more to that and so
with the book it's not frustrating but
you know for me your question was that
people miss something and it's it's that
if they do miss the essence of what this
real this story is about
and I've been you know grateful to see
some reviews and stuff with a book go
much deeper than saying like wow like I
thought I was reading this but actually
this book kept my attention as an
adventure enthusiasts but it was so
interesting to see all these other
layers in the fabric of this book and it
had me crying and it had me laughing and
had me this and I don't think sometimes
I wish that people would kind of go to
that and I understand why they wouldn't
initially you know in a three minute
interview but you know that's the part
of stuff that I care about yeah
click-click yeah yeah
it requires bandwidth and subtlety you
know to really crock the whole thing
yeah yeah that's why I love doing it
this way yeah sure
well let's round this out and end it
with some thoughts on the untapped
reservoirs of human potential that
reside within all of us I think those
are those are themes that we share in
our advocacy and in our work and in our
writing and in our speaking so maybe
reflect on that a little bit and maybe
also since you've just come out of this
Drake experience has any of that like
shifted or or or changed a little bit
from when you wrote it in the book or
where you were at last year compared to
this year you mean the sort of NASA now
you kind of reflect on on transformation
yeah and you know the potential that
resides within us and and you know how
we can how we can better access and
express that in our lives you know it's
something that I've certainly said a lot
and something that I I know that you've
said a lot and something that I've been
inspired by in your work as well is like
that advocacy around that that belief
that you know each one of us have these
reservoirs of untapped potential inside
of us
the Drake Crossing is interesting and
you know I've been asked this question
and derivative is you know callin like
are you a superhuman or oh like what
what's your physiology that makes you so
much different but I also get this
really funny thing and it actually
happened to me two days ago in DC I was
doing this interview and you know
journalist was interviewing me for Fox
and he's like you know I don't really
mmm
I don't mean to say something hopefully
I'm not offending it's like stomach
I've had people say the same thing I
kind of know it was expecting I'm like
it's just that when I read your story I
don't take this the wrong way but you're
like a regular-sized normal looking guy
like I'm not offended he was like it's
just that like I figured like you know
some like six I was gonna come out like
it's a Winkle vibe I've had people come
after speeches and things like that and
say that and to me which certainly is
not offensive I will say in the in the
photos in the book there's a picture of
you on the bike like racing ITU and your
shoulders are looking pretty good no
it's not I'm not to say that like I'm
not fit and this is just that like
you're not like oh god you're like some
like super magically opposing person
yeah and it goes back to that
aspirational aspect though yeah I know
what you do and I think that you know in
you know I've said it kind of
tongue-in-cheek but I do believe it as
well I did believe it actually not just
tongue-in-cheek but in truth and say
like : are you superhuman like yeah I'm
a superhuman and so are you like these
reservoirs of untapped potential reside
inside of all of us and the Drake
Passage row and I'm to kind of have that
through line was for me in writing this
book about the impossible first which
obviously I wrote before I did the Drake
Passage row I really was you know I
still have this thesis of saying like
okay like I am giving this wisdom I'm
sharing my story in the hope that
someone takes the impossible first book
sets it down and starts off on their own
impossible first but where is the proof
in the pudding of that in my own story
obviously there's a lot of through lines
being burned in a fire being told never
walking and recovering etc but the Drake
Row was actually an exercising at this
point in my life of this thesis of
saying okay I tell people all of the
time you have a massive goal but you
haven't started on it yet or you're a
beginner or you have this huge idea but
you're a novice and you look at all the
other people who are so much better at
you like I'm sure people say to you all
the time like god I want to start a
podcast but like podcasts are so
saturated right now we're like you know
you've already got millions of listeners
like how could I ever catch up to and
you're like yeah but like in 2012 or
whenever was I was sitting in Kauai and
like a garage and I like hit play on a
tape recorder with mic
kids around and like started talking
into a microphone and so for me the
Drake Row was my own way of saying like
yes I'm not trying to pretend like I
don't have other accomplishments in my
past we all have a path that has led us
to today to this moment who we are but
can you then put something on the
proverbial whiteboard for yourself that
allows you to stretch and reach and to
grow that actually exercises that muscle
of taking that step towards it and for
me it was to step into a place of
endurance sports that I've never touched
not even tangentially with ocean and
rowing and etc and so I believe I mean
III core believe that we have these
reservoirs of untapped potential and the
muscle it's not the physical imposition
imposing you know character that I could
or couldn't be I guess just the person
that I am but I say that the muscle
that's the most important to any of us
is the six inches between our ears it's
within our minds it's what we can create
and I think that that really dictates a
lot of this I yeah that's how I believe
phenomenally articulated I mean I look
at the Drake Passage experience as
basically the manifestation or a
manifestation of this sort of Angela
Duckworth Carol Dweck like growth
mindset like you're not a rower okay
like you're an athlete like it would
have been easier for you to pick some
other kind of like expedition with which
is you just you know doing what you've
always kind of done or whatever right
exactly but to put yourself in a
situation that that you know in many
ways is just completely unfamiliar and
new I think it's really cool and I think
that does convey that message of like
hey man I you know like I'm you know I'm
trying to learn this stuff as well and
I'm gonna put I'm gonna I'm gonna be you
know I'm going to walk the talk
basically totally and I think also the
other thing is I think we've all had
that kind of you know impostor syndrome
of in a room of certain people were like
well I don't belong here I'm not good
enough to be here I think anyone who's
ever walked into a cocktail party or
something has had that feeling at some
point in their life you know I certainly
have a lot of times and you know even on
my Instagram if you saw when I posted
hey I'm doing this project and here's
this amazing team and have come together
and here's what all these other guys
have accomplished I mean you brought it
up earlier in this interview I'm not
offended by it at all and some
like well you're obviously the weak link
like in all of this and so the easiest
thing for me to do would have been to
say I was literally the first person
history ever to cross an article solo
people have died attempting this exact
crossing and I did it so let me be now
the master of that domain
why would I line myself side-by-side up
in a situation next to guys who are like
been spending decades crushing this
sport that they're exceptionally good
with with world record hold you know
record records around their neck and
accolades you know you know list of
accolades is you know a page long but
it's like having the humility to say
like but I still want to grow I still
want to learn I still want to like learn
from them and hopefully I am bringing
something you know valuable to the table
beyond just you know sort of the the
logistics or resources to be able to do
something like this and but humbly I'm
gonna come into this and I think you
know if they were sitting here they
would say wow yeah like from a physical
level mental level we all learn
something from each other but it takes
it's a humbling moment to go when I
don't have to go stand next to people in
this other domain it'll be in my own
little area and so I think in any Avenue
as we begin to set out on things people
can feel that way people can feel like
oh you know like you were you're like
you're probably a great lawyer at what
you were doing you hated it whatever I
mean a long time you know and to like
just redefine your identity you know you
turn into an incredible endurance
athlete but I imagine I don't know the
story of your very first triathlon but I
imagine it was like you're like I'm just
a guy I trust my shoes you know whatever
and so it's it's taking that but that is
how these interesting moments grow and
so don't be held back by being like I
don't know how to do this right now I'm
not good at this my neighbor's better
than me at the guy around the water
cooler he's the expert at this that or
the other thing it's like why not start
somewhere
he started somewhere he had day one at
his job or his expert or his skill at
some point as well like your day could
be today I thought you'd be bigger
sorry to disappoint awesome man thank
you beautiful I love you Colin Oh Brady
I love you thank you for your example
all the incredible work and advocacy
that you
do and I know we'll continue to do the
book is extraordinary the impossible
first I love it man and I'm just I'm
happy to be in your life you like
grateful for our friendship and I wish
you the best of luck please pick up oh
you have Angela Duckworth right there on
the cover author of great thought you
were no no I was like well you were
talking about growth mindset I was deep
yeah yeah that's very cool phenomenal
man if you want to hook up with Colin
Colin or Brady on Instagram is probably
the best place right yeah and website
collaborative all right love you peace
[Music]